[Music]
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
Kos and um today I am so happy to bring
one of my childhood favorite characters
from I believe is like 1992 when Marvel
was doing this whole shake up trying to
get readers more involved but prime once
studios captured this statue in the
perfect light in all his glory I give
you none other than spider-man 2099 now
a lot of guys ask me um hey King why
this spider-man though this spider-man
is probably my favorite spider-man to be
honest with you right because he's of
Mexican and Irish descent his name is
Miguel O'Hara okay so he's not Peter
Parker and enough ultimate dimension or
alternate reality he is far in the
future 2099 and the way he becomes
spider-man is completely different you
know uh he debuted in spider-man 2099
issue 1 and it was it was it was a nice
take on a character now listen this is
how he became he didn't get bit by a
spider he was a scientist right and he
worked for his corporation his boss was
evil and his boss got him addicted to
this drug so on this drug
which he would charge enormous amounts
of money that these guys were highly
addicted to to keep them in order to
keep them working so what he what he did
he's decided to rewrite his genetic code
to write out the addiction to the drug
smart right fantastic but there was an
employee that was working there as well
that would was willing to do anything to
climb the ladder so what the employee
did while he's rewriting his genetic
code the employee came and hit all the
levels up on the arm on the computer and
the sequences right blow up the lab so
he gets bombarded with all this genetic
code rewriting and he you know escapes
from the lab he gets the suit now excuse
me
the suit is where this comes in from
right this is this is where the Mexican
comes in he was celebrating the day of
the day this is actually a costume from
the Day of the Dead now on the way home
with the Day of the Dead costume that he
had on it was a Thor worshipper right
because you know that Thor 2099 he used
his like is this glider stuff it looks
like webbing so is it like a glider cake
but it's tattered so that's what it
looks like webbing so that allows him to
glide right whereas the regular
spider-man produces webbing by he makes
the webbing in the web-shooters this
spider-man has organic web shooters
right it comes out of his skin he has
spinach like real spiders that shoots he
makes the web out of his body do you
remember that when Sony did that and
they had that in that spider-man movie
Oh Tobey Maguire was making web fluid it
was you know they was trying to
reference this guy and trying to make it
happen but no he's not Peter Parker he's
Miguel O'Hara then yes he has organic
wedding he doesn't make webbing he
you know it comes out of his body right
now this is the complete differences
between this spider-man and our amazing
spider-man as he has claws his claws are
they can cut through steel they all his
fingertips all right and that's what he
uses to click stick to walls and stuff
like that and he's able to you know
glide from here to there yes super
strength but the big difference is he
does not have a spidey sense he doesn't
have the Peter tingle right so I gotta
yell out paws on my head the Peter
Taylor yell out paws but he doesn't have
that and that's the biggest difference
between 2099 and amazing spider-man
Peter Parker they did cross paths and
alternate realities they did merge you
know he did fight the superior
spider-man and hopefully I can get a
superior spider-man statue whenever one
is made because I did like that and I
will go into detail on who the superior
spider-man is that's a secret for later
on but um I got a couple of statues in
you know from eBay and this one was from
a facebook friend of mine and great
statue a group and the statue came
through and he had it for a great price
normally you can catch these statues at
aftermarket for 1,200 on eBay I got a
foot decent price so I had to pull the
trigger on it always wanted to statue
I thought the statue is fantastic and
let's get into prime ones rendition of
2099 amazing whoa not amazing 2099
spider-man
now this statue was one of the hardest
bases to put together it's a very
intricate base with into weavings is
like a coat of not a kaleidoscope like a
um uneven mmm a gyroscope it's like a
gyroscope within the ball right that
he's standing on and that ball lights up
as you're gonna see in pictures later in
a picture right here you can see that it
turns different colors right as it goes
if you're watching it in the background
you'll see purple you see red you see
yellow and it has a battery inside of it
and a small computer chip that's inside
of it that it does this you push down on
the middle of the spare and it turns
many different colors the smoke is a
clear resin and surround the bottom the
webbing that goes around on the outside
looks very metallic silk ish a very
heavy thread the suit on him is so well
done priming one studios does great work
very intricate okay so when you look at
the red the red pops the blue pops the
texture in the costume is fantastic you
can see the claws in the hand and looks
great the facial definition you don't
see seams in the character because he's
one whole piece right so is the base as
many different pieces probably like 15
20 pieces total um it comes with this
picture this is the diagram right here
that if you have to follow this diagram
front and back
thank God they put this inside the box
because you would never put the statue
together be honest with you a lot of
different moving parts to it and it
finally comes together in this dynamic
pose
I am so happy to have this statue I am
so happy to be able to bring the statue
to you this is one of the premiere
spider-man that I wanted until I can
find an amazing spider-man I think this
is gonna be my spider-man centerpiece
until that can happen I have a couple
more of villains of spider-man that I
will be debuting over the next couple of
weeks but this is prime ones studios
2099 spider-man and it is truly
outstanding if anyone happens to have
this piece it's an older piece but it's
new to me and it's new to you right you
got a chance to see it I got a chance to
bring it to you and I'm happy we get a
chance to share this together so this is
the part of the video when I asked you
to like follow and subscribe and also
hit that joint button hit that joint
button down at the bottom of follow the
iron Lords joined up with the iron Lords
as with those two these trade shows and
also go to loads of gaming dotnet we can
see a ton of opinion pieces ton of
reviews hard gamer reviews by the Lord
addict he is one of the best guys out
here playing these games and he conquers
these hard games without any problems
like Woody's is truly something to see
also we have the last word with Lord
Cognito and bond tests and all episodes
of Kos that you can see and combat talk
with the king listen guys stick around
watch this video it has tons of pictures
it has extra video that you can see the
statue up closer you can see the
intricacies that I'm talking about this
is an amazing statue and I'm so happy
that you can sharing this with me and
also I want you to stay collecting see
you next week when a new episode of
fearless
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]